well let's talk to the adviser to the
israeli prime minister
mark regev good to see you this morning
mr regev look
the israeli defense minister has said in
the last few hours israel is not
preparing for a ceasefire
there is no end date for the operation
only when we achieve complete
quiet can we talk about calm what does
that mean
i think i think he's he's trying to say
that we don't want our band-aid quick
fix i need to see everything explode
again tomorrow
i mean waiting hamas hard and the truth
is they they're
very happy for us to stop but just to
have them regroup and get our time out
and then for them to get us again
tomorrow there's no point in that
this has been going on for too long and
we need a solution that will be
sustainable
but the the solution surely isn't to
to bomb hamas out of existence is it
no one said that but hamas has to
understand that shooting rockets into
israel is unacceptable
and can't be considered a norm and we
have to very firmly
very firmly and make sure that we're not
going to come out of this just to
re-enter it again in in the near future
it must be remembered who we're talking
about we're talking about a territory
where the palestinian government has no
authority whatsoever
where hamas has taken over hamas a
terrorist organization not just
i the israeli government says that the
uk government the eu
the americans the canadians the japanese
even across the arab world
the arabs accept the recognition of
hamas they recognize hamas as a
terrorist organization
this is a group of fanatics with a very
extreme agenda who have no
qualms whatsoever about shooting
hundreds of rockets in innocent
civilians
so how far is is israel prepared to go
to quell this i mean there is talk about
a ground invasion
being at least approved even if no
immediate plans
are in place for that
obviously we have to look at all
possible contingencies we would be
irresponsible to do otherwise but we
will
do what we need to do to protect our
civilian population as i believe the
british government would do to protect
the british
population and of course our goal is to
bring about
long-term peace and quiet we want to see
a situation
where israeli civilians don't have to
live in fear of an incoming rocket sent
by gaza
we've had now three nights in a row
where the sirens have been going off in
major population centers in israel where
people are being running to the bomb
shelters my family included
this is a a difficult time but there's
no point
as i said before to have some sort of a
band-aid quick fix only to go through
all this again next week
we want to come out of this with a
sustained period of quiet
we want to we want a new reality where
we don't have to live fear in fear of
these incoming rockets
i think i mean you talk about the
importance of safety for civilians
everybody understands that but what
about palestinian civilians we
know we think 65 people in gaza have
died how many of those were civilians we
don't know apart from the number
that there are at least 14 palestinian
children who've died
i mean a lot of people are looking at
this and saying you know although they
understand
the need for israel to defend itself
this is
not a proportional response
well i want you to say i want to say
first off that we don't want to see
anyone
uh innocent people caught up in the
crossfire between us and hamas
we don't want to see anyone hurt
unnecessarily and of course
heaven forbid children that's the last
thing we want to see i mean every time
a child is killed israeli or palestinian
it's a tragedy
it shouldn't happen but we face a very
difficult dilemma here
because hamas is actually committing a
double war crime they are not only
indiscriminately shooting at israeli
civilians
bombarding our cities with volley after
volley after of rocket but at the same
time they implant their terrorist
military machine
inside civilian neighborhoods they fire
from mosques from school
from schools to built up areas and if we
want to take out their rocket launchers
we have to try to be as surgically as is
possible
in in in a very very complex combat
situation
often with civilians in the vicinity now
we try to be as surgical as we can we
don't want to hit the civilians
but hamas in doing so is committing a
second war crime not only are they
attacking israeli civilians but they're
deliberately exploiting and abusing the
gaza civilian population
as a human shield for their military
terrorist machine
i mean you you talk about them
committing war crimes one
of uh of our mps over here who
who has a palestinian mum as it goes but
she's been
looking at the situation in sheikh
jarrah and saying
well that in itself from the actions
that israel is taking is
is breaking the fourth geneva convention
i i i beg to disagree what you have in
sheikh is is a land dispute between
between two different groups two
different uh individuals
where you have property there were jews
living in czech church before the 1948
war
and they now claim that they want to
return to that property now the israeli
government hasn't taken a side in the
court case
but this is a land dispute but surely we
can all agree that in any land dispute
there does not have to be violence there
definitely doesn't have to be an excuse
for people to send missiles into israel
but in terms of stepping back from the
brink here which the international
community
is really calling for really trying to
apply pressure
on both sides here to do that wouldn't
stopping this
whatever is going on in shake gerard at
the moment putting a pause on that
trying to take a step back trying to get
behind the negotiating table again
be a really important move at this stage
i think it's important to remember that
the problem here is hamas
the palestinian government is someone
we've negotiated with in the past and we
can negotiate with in the future but
hamas
is a terrorist organization that if you
read their charter
they say every israeli is a legitimate
target man woman and child they don't
believe
in negotiations they believe in
destroying israel they're very extreme
in their
views they've been called a jihadist
organization
they're part of a islamic radical sort
of world view
that believes my country should be
destroyed and all the civilians in it
should uh should face death this is not
a group that believes in negotiations in
fact
the the first huge wave of hamas
violence happened during when the peace
process was in high gear during the
years of the oslo process then we were
told hamas is killing people because
they want to end the peace process now
if you're telling me today they're doing
it because there's no peace process well
you can't have it both ways
hamas is killing israelis because that's
what they do they have to stop doing so
mark rugev good to talk to you today
thank you